first of all i want to say this
my purpose when i come on to your show
and i reframe the questions
is not to challenge you i can
sit inside all of those it's to give you
better audio and video because i think
we've been on an
incredible role i really love what you
do and so i am trying to honor you by
being
as disagreeable about frame breaking as
possible i think some of your listeners
don't understand
that it's actually a sign of respect as
opposed to some sort of a
complex dynamic which is i think you can
play outside
of some of the frames and that these are
sort of offerings to get the
conversation started so let me try to
break that frame and give you something
different
beautiful i think what's going on here
is that um i can prove
effectively that we're not thinking
about this in very deep terms as soon as
i say we've got to get off this planet
the number of people who assume that i'm
talking about faster than light travel
is very high and faster than light
travel assumes some sort of
einsteinian paradigm that then is broken
by some small adjustment and i think
that
that's fascinating it shows me that our
failure to imagine what could be being
said
is profound we don't have an idea
um of all of the difference different
ways in which
we might be able to visit distant worlds
all we think about is okay it must be it
must be einsteinian space times
and then some means of exceeding the
speed limit and
it's just it's fascinating to me that we
don't really have
we've lost the ability to just realize
we don't know the framework
you